at the end of September Amazon Prime
video will make sure its subscribers are
ready for Halloween the last day of the
month will see the edition of scary
flicks like Cloverfield event horizon
and tales from the dark side the movie
may be because of the big influx Primus
and adding quite as many movies and TV
shows in October but what the lineup
lacks in quantity it makes up for in
quality as of October 2019 the Amazon
Prime original Goliath will be three
years old I hate you very much
the first season of the legal drama
starring Billy Bob Thornton as a
washed-up lawyer seeking to atone for
past mistakes premiered in October 2016
fans had to wait two years for a second
season and fortunately they only had to
wait after time for a third at the end
of October the 1993 crime film killing
Zoey is heading to prime video Eric
Stoltz stars in his American French film
in the vein of early Quentin Tarantino
films of the time earlier in the month
however will get a decidedly different
kind of film October first brings a 2009
animated film Astro Boy to prime astro
boy follows the adventures of a young
boy who's killed and then resurrected as
a robot superhero it may have been
suffered first for margin John Krasinski
as an action hero but Prime's original
Jack Ryan change that in a big way when
Krasinski took on the role of Tom
Clancy's most recognizable protagonist
Jack Ryan isn't the first time the hero
has been adapted to the screen Harrison
Ford played the CIA analyst twice
beginning with the espionage thriller
patriarch games which is set to arrive
on prime on October 1st in this 1992
film Ryan is stressed into the role of
hero when while on vacation in London he
witnesses an attack on members of the
English royal family
Ryan had left the CIA before the events
of the film returns to his former job so
he can take the reins of the efforts to
capture the terrorists I will put such a
stranglehold on your gun money he'll be
having the street drawn rocks
adding to the already long list of
horror titles being added to Prime at
the end of September October 3rd brings
high life to the streaming service
starring Robert Pattinson and Julia
panache high life is a sci-fi horror
film following a group of convicts sent
to explore a black hole Haley Joel
Osment who initially won widespread
recognition as the boy who could see
dead people in M night Shyamalan the
Sixth Sense has been enjoying some
prominent roles in recent series like
future man and the boys but if you'd
like a chance to see him back when he
was beardless
prime offers a chance on October 1st
when ad Steven Spielberg's
AI artificial
intelligence to his library set in the
not-too-distant future AI is about a
young robot boy whose programming
sometimes allows for the capacity to
love Jude Law start alongside Osment as
gigolo Joe a robot sex worker on the run
while primes original Goliath brings us
a fresh mystery in October later in the
month the streaming service will add the
third season of the British crime drama
unforgotten
which focuses on mysteries so old that
everyone else has given up on them in
unforgotten stud season Detective Chief
Inspector Cassie Stewart and her partner
Sonny tackle a case almost two decades
old
DCI castewart and di Sonny Khan when
workers on a highway and covered the
remains of a 16 year old girl who was
reported missing in 2000 it gets the
hero's attention unforgotten sports
season has been confirmed and dis likely
to release either later this year or in
2020 if you're a prime subscriber
looking to get caught up for the
upcoming season this looks like the
perfect opportunity check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the pal so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]